les chéris je sais pas si vous avez vu
ce coup de tonnerre à la télé américaine
c'est un marasme
hier l'émission de téléréalité la plus
culte de l'histoire mais l'incroyable
famille kardashian va s'arrêter après 20
saisons et 14 ans d'antenne et plus de
250 épisodes là ce sont qui arrive en
2021 sera donc la dernière pourtant les
audiences étaient très bonnes à 2,4
millions de téléspectateurs ont suivi le
scandale d'infidélité entre chloé et
tristan thompson 1 pendant la saison 16
c'est vraiment un événement à la télé
américaine vous a préparé un petit
magnéto parce que ça c'est vraiment la
plus grosse télé réalité qui existe dans
le monde et c'est fini on regarde ceux
qui l'ignorent encore kim carnation et
l'une des plus grandes stars actuelles
pourtant elle n'est ni chanteuse ni
mannequin et actrice elle et kim
kardashian star de la télé réalité
devenu célèbre suite à la diffusion de
sa sextape avec son mari reggie en 2007
elle a très vite su surfer sur ce buzz
éphémère est resté sous le feu des
projecteurs c'est avec l'aide de sa
maman et managers crise génère qu'elle a
l'idée de lancer une télé réalité autour
de sa famille richissime l'incroyable
famille kardashian une émission grâce à
laquelle les téléspectateurs ont pu
assister à des moments cultes de la
transformation physique de ses soeurs en
passant par la relation entre kim
kardashian et kanye west
sauf qu'aujourd'hui voilà c'est un
véritable coup de tonnerre qui vient de
retentir
après plus de 14 années à l'antenne kim
kardashian vient d'annoncer sur les
réseaux sociaux que l'incroyable famille
kardashian tirer officiellement sa
révérence à nos incroyables fans c'est
le coeur lourd que nous avons pris la
décision difficile en tant que famille
de dire au revoir leurs draps bleus
famille kardashian avec amour gratitude
team les fans du programme pourront
toujours se consoler avec la toute
dernière saison de l'émission qui sera
diffusée au début de l'année 2000 21 aux
etats unis
les soeurs kardashian on vous le sachiez
kim kardashian la 188 millions d'abonnés
sur un serveur chaque publication
sponsorisé peut lui rapporter jusqu'à
1,2 million de dollars par poste
regardez j'ai mangé des kellogg's corn
flakes et ben voilà à dernier le 2
millions j'ai mangé un dragibus but il a
vécu avec du doc
je me suis cassé à 9 soit et est à base
d'orge masses d'eau gelée bon je les ai
fermé à l'union de tous c'est un truc de
ouf
elle a gagné en 2019 49,5 millions de
dollars comme benhaim sans la coiffure
et voilà donc c'est vraiment c'est
incroyable et c'est vrai que ça s'arrête
alors je vais vous montrer parce qu'il
ya des extraits incroyable de cette
téléréalité par exemple aux tout débuts
en 2007 qu'à la soeur de kim kardashian
est clos et à les placer en garde à vue
pour conduite en état d'ivresse et sauf
que kim a là une réaction un peu chelou
elle s'est prise en selle fille dans la
voiture qui a mené sa soeur derrière les
barreaux et tranquille quoi et c'est
mieux peut-être prendre un million et
que ces conneries mais nettement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
montrez typiquement l'extrait qui fait
que cette série fait cette téléréalité a
rendu les gens totalement accro on
assiste à une famille absolument
dysfonctionnelle comme on en a jamais vu
sur 10 fonction de sao tomé et qui sont
fiers de l'être et qui sont heureux
qu'ils aient qui montre mais chaque
instant le pdu plus privée juste plus
large de lundi la question mais dans ce
volet c'est que c'est un exemple pour
tous les jeunes et beaucoup de sms que
vous comprenez que ce soit un exemple
pour tous les jeunes ou est ce que vous
vous dites franchement c'est
catastrophique parce que c'est ça
peut-être la société d'aujourd'hui
puisque un autre extrait que voulez vous
montrer c'est lors d'un voyage en
famille à bora bora en 2011
l'ex fiancée de kim kardashian kim
kardashian la science dans la mer et kim
père une boucle d'oreille en diamant
d'une valeur de 75 mille dollars
et là c'est le drame regardez
[Musique]
on va
je veux dire c'est des tarés gibert les
stocks comprenez que ce soient des
exemples
oui franchement alors il ya des dérives
mais ils sont iconique ils ont
transformé à leur nom en marque mondiale
vous citiez les chiffres alors ça a créé
des divisions au sein de la famille
courtney la soeur notamment voulais que
ça s'arrête
mais franchement je comprends parce que
c'est un modèle de réussite alors qu'ali
ben tu appelle ça un modèle de réussite
de faire une sextape de faire la file et
grâce à ça que ce soit ça me propre
maman qui les instrumentalisent que ce
soit moi je trouve ça vraiment mais
déplorable que ce soit un modèle pour et
je pense sincèrement que ces personnes
c'est encore calculé parce que toute
leur vie calculée
je pense qu'elles arrêtent leur télé
réalité parce qu'elles savent très bien
qu'elles n'ont plus besoin alors parce
que tout va se jouer sur les réseaux et
vous encore plus clairement qu'il est
encore en plus en donner alors je vous
dis rien un événement c'est une famille
quand même alors barbet il ya un
événement aussi
voilà qui a marqué l'émission de la
famille perd 6 en 2015 ya bruce jenner
c'est le beau père de kim kardashian qui
lui si la décision sur l'échec si la
plaie très simple voilà et en 2015
il a décidé de changer de sexe et de
s'appeler kateline il avait dû expliquer
son choix ses fils biologique
un moment qui avait été énormément suivi
à l'époque regardez la réaction de kim
kardashian qui se pose beaucoup beaucoup
de questions sur l'anatomie de son père
est tous assez film et c'est là qu'est
la photo du changement mais 400 à la
limite pardonnez moi mais ça fait bouger
les lignes en amérique puritaine dans
une amérique qui a du mal à accepter la
différence et tout ça là pour le coup
moi ça mettre en scène sa et le montrer
et montrer à quel point ce type là
pendant des années c'est mentir à
lui-même et plaxo feront la traversée ça
pour le coup c'est la seule chose que je
dirais oui mettons la lumière j'en
oublie pas la seule
bonjour j
j'adore latéralité mais là c'est
pathétique je suis d'accord avec kelly
mais le problème c'est pas qu'elle ait
fait que l'histoire soit basée sur une
sextape c'est qu'elle fait une sextape
que sa mère la regardant dit c'est pas
assez pour nous donc tulard face à face
à soi plus loin on démarre dans un
espace aussi cédé exemple pour tout le
monde à tous mais oui je viens dans
toutes les filles de téléralité toutes
les filles à l'intérieur leur objectif
c'est la ligue et jenner ou kim
kardashian dernièrement voilà j'essaie
d'être connu maintenant c'est connu
métier rien ouais moi je trouve
qu'effectivement c'est une réussite
extraordinaire c'est une multinationale
elle fait que des produits dérivés
aujourd'hui tout fonctionne d'ailleurs
il ya elle a annoncé par ailleurs que ça
allait s'arrêter en télé réalité et elle
sort un parfum pile au même moment ben
oui donc c'est ça qui compte aujourd'hui
comme ça qu'elles gagnent qu'elle gagne
pas à saborder valorisée à 1 milliard de
dollars
oui on regarde comme modèle c'est
catastrophique c'est le règne de
marseille c'est le modèle si vous nous
regardait vaincu belliciste et hissé le
modèle actuel alors être tous lit mon
but c'est de venir kim kardashian kylie
jenner alors comme il l'avait fait la
région les tchèques son père il y a un
truc qui avait fait beaucoup parler
si la rencontre entre bruce donc devenu
kathleen et son ex femme
kris jenner qu'il a revu son ex femme
mais en femme cette fois ci regardée aux
états unis l'aipac et à cet âge que le
stockage
voilà alors oui je suis pas d'accord
avec mes collègues parce que je trouve
que vous êtes trop analytique
ils sont dans l'émotion ils ont voulu
montrer leur vison osé ils ont cassé
tous les codes c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
une exhibition mais je suis désolé ils
ont ils ont osé faire ce que personne
n'osera et la raison j'en ai quatre ans
les éditions lexicalisation outre un
extrait on voit une des soeurs kourtney
avec képi l'entrejambes de son autre
soeur khloé d'affilée en frais sai
cerizay les melons accrochant des gens
feraient sens plein gré des heures
regarde
non la crama oui je vais jamais qu'une
émotion en amérique on peut rien montré
eux voilà ils vont extrêmement - est
contré sur pense et je pense que c'est
un énorme business ils sont moins bêtes
bien le contraire et tout ça est calculé
maîtrisé et c'est un business à travers
sûr que les athées ou croyants
ça doit être un exemple on est encore là
c'est pas mal mais on avait supprimé des
jeunes c'est pas pire que les anges de
la télé réalité en face ils s'amusent en
eau non non on peut pas dire ça ce que
c'est que ça marche ça cartonne et quand
ça cartonne sa gêne voilà 6 à sa main
désormais vous pouvez pas le truc c'est
que même les anges les marseillais ça
leur rêve c'est d'être kim kardashian
verte alors oui c'est aussi penser à
dire maintenant c'est à dire que c'est
qui qui s'appelait zabel vous ma peau
nettement c'est un peu comme vous je
pense et voilà il comme le père de lui
aux carnations le regain d'intérêt que
vous dire que même en france les
nouveaux d'appeler arrêtés sont
extrêmement mal un dans le temps dans
leur business et c'est tout ce qu'ils
font c'est maîtrisé et comment ce que je
pense et je pense même qu'ils
travaillent beaucoup plus qu'on peut
l'imaginer
moi je pense que pour les jeunes
effectivement ça vous gêne et parce que
il suffit de trous de balle mais mais
mais mais au final honnêtement c'est
très réussi c'est très maîtrisée
effectivement s'il est jeune mais elle
est en mode mais pourquoi et pourquoi
pas d'accord c'est quoi pas se laisser
dégrader si son image sa famille se
désintéresse pas dégrader volontairement
kelly mais ils le font volontairement
mais en fait c'est toi tout pour
l'argent ça veut dire qu'on peut montrer
son cul son trou de balle se faire
épiler là tout le monde non cuisse a
peut être ses fesses le trou de balle
c'est autre chose
oh ben non
solitaire mais aussi monstrueux et
l'autre n'est pas dire tout bas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
aussi fascinant que monstrueux on se
trompe sur les prem's effectivement pas
de l'émotion c'est dumas qui dit oui
mario silva eut pas les émissions de
carbone chiens les imiter et c'est en ça
que ça reste oui voilà oui ah oui % non
à 92